en el último vídeo estábamos hablando de
la empresa de zapatos de bebé en el cual
tenía un costo por acción de 21 pesos
con 50 centavos por acción y esta
empresa tenía 10.000 acciones voy a
mover un poco la pantalla para que
ustedes lo vean 10.000 acciones de hecho
ambas tienen 10.000 acciones y fue en el
vídeo pasado en donde calculamos la
capitalización bursátil la cual nos daba
215 mil pesos ojo también habíamos
mencionado que el valor contable o el
capital de esta empresa era de 135 mil
pesos y que no es lo mismo que la
capitalización bursátil en este vídeo lo
que yo quiero es analizar o calcular
cómo podemos encontrar el activo o los
bienes de la compañía debe no es jugado
caso de la compañía de jason no importa
de ambas empresas ahora bien lo primero
que hay que recordar es lo siguiente el
activo lo podemos ver como el pasivo es
decir las cuentas a pagar más el
patrimonio total
ahora bien el patrimonio total lo veamos
calculado en el vídeo pasado cuando
nosotros hablábamos acerca de la
capitalización bursátil es 215 mil pesos
hay que saber cuántos son las deudas a
pagar pues nosotros nos fijamos aquí en
donde dice deudas a pagar son cinco mil
pesos por lo tanto ya podemos calcular
de manera sencilla nuestro activo
nuestro activo va a ser el pasivo o las
cuentas a pagar que son cinco mil pesos
ya esto hay que sumarle los 215.000 del
patrimonio total que teníamos
anteriormente por lo tanto ahora sí
podemos decir que el activo van a ser
220 mil pesos muy bien no hay que
olvidar que hablamos de la compañía de
venta también si de nosotros recordamos
lo que hemos visto en vídeos pasados el
valor contable de nuestro activo son 140
mil pesos porque tenemos 20 mil pesos en
efectivo más 100 mil pesos en inventario
más 20 mil pesos en equipo también lo
podemos ver como la maquinaria de la
empresa ahora bien la pregunta indicada
es si el valor contable de nuestros
activos es de 140 mil pesos es decir el
efectivo más el inventario más la
maquinaria son 140 mil pesos porque el
valor del activo total es de 220 mil
pesos en qué radica esta diferencia es
decir si nosotros vamos al mercado y
preguntamos cuánto vale nuestro activo
nos va
en nuestro pasivo más la capitalización
bursátil es decir los 220 mil pesos
porque hay esta gran diferencia entre el
valor de 140 mil pesos y el valor de 220
mil pesos donde queda esta diferencia en
el valor que nosotros tenemos ahora bien
si suponemos que todo lo que estamos
haciendo lo estamos haciendo bien
pensando en los bienes materiales
siempre el capital va a ser mayor al
valor contable de nuestra empresa y más
aún en el mercado esto se le conoce como
bienes inmateriales los bienes en
materiales son aquellos que no puedes
sentir es más no les puedes poner un
dedo encima pero ellos hacen que la
compañía sea más que la suma de sus
partes el valor de la compañía es más
grande que el valor del equipo más
grande que el valor del inventario y más
grande que el valor del efectivo que
tienen y es que esta es una de las
experiencias administrativas que más se
disfrutan porque nos dicen que estamos
haciendo bien las cosas es decir que el
negocio va bastante bien ahora vamos a
fijarnos qué es lo que pasa con la
empresa de zapatos de jason si te das
cuenta es muy parecido a la empresa de
zapatos de ben tenemos que el patrimonio
total o la capital
bursátil es de 120 mil pesos que los
tenemos aquí ya esto le agregamos 100
mil pesos de pasivo más 5 mil pesos de
deudas a pagar por lo tanto tenemos 5
mil más 100 mil más 120 mil que son 200
225 mil pesos si se bien la suma a ver
cinco mil más cien mil más 120 mil son
225 mil pesos ok entonces tenemos un
activo de 225 mil pesos 225 mil pesos y
de la misma manera que la compañía deben
si nosotros nos fijamos en el valor
contable de sus activos o en sus bienes
tenemos una cantidad de 140 mil pesos
por lo tanto nuestro bien inmaterial es
este que tenemos aquí que sería la
diferencia entre 225 mil pesos y 140 mil
pesos y ahora si lo que vamos a ver en
el siguiente vídeo es cuál de estas dos
empresas es la mejor empresa
considerando que ambas son empresas muy
parecidas